with the credit because of the credit
with the sounds our critic hello if you
haven't heard made the past five times
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I fucking
love Animaniacs I mean think about it
is there any show from our childhood
that was better written better animated
or better handled than this masterpiece
okay that was pretty good
but Animaniacs was still incredible what
great jokes what great music what
absolutely unforgettable characters and
today I'm paying homage to one of the
greatest shows ever and if I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it right
as well as
Italian stallion consult the heavyweight
champion of the world
let's go he's not in this but still we
have a big chunk of the people who made
one of the greatest guys thank you so
much for coming on the show and
answering my stupid questions this is so
awesome let's not waste any time
uh I guess the first thing to start off
with is how you guys all got involved
with this show and the person to
probably start with is Tom because am i
right you've pretty much written for
every cartoon show ever created I need
your backgrounds incredible it's like
he-man scooby-doo all these huge shows
so you probably had the longest
experience in animation right I was I
started as an assistant animator slash
in-betweener and then made it up to
animator I began work out here at
hanna-barbera just kind of bizarre
things like shirttails & Snorks I got a
chance to story at it and co produce a
bunch of Scooby series then they gave me
a shot to do a new version which turned
out to be a pup named scooby-doo
and in that one we did a lot of sort of
text every wild takes and that show
Believe It or Not was what landed me the
gig on Tiny Toons I started out as an
actress back 100 million years ago and I
was I was in The Groundlings I performed
at The Groundlings and a friend of mine
at The Groundlings asked if I'd be
interested in maybe writing a cartoon
this was for Tiny Toons actually so I'd
never written anything before but I'm a
huge fan of the old Warner Brothers
cartoons so I got hired on staff for
Tiny Toons and Animaniacs came along and
I jumped at the chance to develop that
along with Tom Ruger and everybody
growing up it was either sports or being
funny or or being preyed upon so I chose
funny Paul and I at the time were in a
group called Acme comedy theater which
is a run by sherry stoners husband she
had already been you know brought on
board for Tiny Toons and other shows and
when they started looking for writers
for Animaniacs they came down they said
these guys are you know lean and
unemployed they'll probably work cheaply
they're correct
so when Animaniacs was coming up she
thought she just give you know John
a script and when they were first
developing it and based on that that
hired us now how did the actual creation
of the show go down like what was the
process
well Animaniacs came from this whole
success at Warner Brothers where we had
made Tiny Toons and mr. Spielberg and
gene mccurdy and a bunch of people
decided well we have to make the sequel
now we were looking for the lead
characters for the show Stephen said we
need a billboard name we can't just go
out there with nobody that's stuck in my
head billboard character so I was
walking across the lot one day I saw the
water tower and I thought well that's
kind of a you know sort of a billboard
as far as the Warner Brothers go the
initial creation of that was Tom Ruger's
I remember it being first based on his
three kids that were three sons that
were very small at the time and just the
chaotic element of having them in his
life made him want to do something like
that what we did was we put a whole
bunch of cartoon concepts together
thinking the brain slappy squirrel and
we took them all over to Stephens house
on a Saturday morning which was an
appropriate time we all have like
cookies and milk
Tom would put them up on the big board
he had this big big board in this office
and he would pin up names of characters
that we pitched and different things
like that and they then the artists
would do drawings of different
characters and they sort of evolved as
time went on and some fell by the
wayside some sucked the last one to make
the cut was minion buttons and minion
buttons were been jettisoned earlier in
our little meeting and then Stephens
family came including a bunch of little
kids and they went over to the minion
buttons pictures and said I lack so
suddenly minion buttons were back in
they had a Bible which was literally I
remember it was like two inches thick
and it was pretty much all said about
what they would be there was a list like
five pages about what they thought the
character's catchphrases would be Paul
and I had to kind of you know feel our
way you know try to use some of the
stuff they had and then some ideas that
we had I remember Deana Oliver kept
pushing this gecko and chuckwalla and of
course it ultimately turned into the
Geico gecko so Deana also was the one
behind Chicken boo
she said we have to do this chicken and
no one realizes it's really a chicken
and and it made no sense and yet we made
probably 10 of them in a colander
basically did the Katie kaboom deal
based on his daughter and of course
Sherri stoner is was and always will be
a slappy squirrel Thank You mr.
exposition she brought that character in
from like a groundling skit that she had
done so we basically took the concept of
screwy squirrel who we all loved from
the Texas Avery cartoons and turning
that character into sort of elderly
cranky squirrel pinking the brain of
course famously were based on two of our
artists Tom Minton as the brain and
Eddie Fitzgerald as pinky basically
those two characters were based around
the personalities of those two
writer-director artists mitten and and
Eddie Fitzgerald would be in the room
next door you know and you'd hear mitten
go and Eddie goes north really that's
where the whole pinky the brain concept
came from because I always felt that
they were planning to take over the
world now that's interesting because I
always thought maybe pinky was Hugh
Laurie from Black Adder or something and
I could have sworn that brain was Orson
Welles he looks and talks like Orson
Welles was very inspiration for that the
the voice actor doing the brain the
beloved more maurice lamarche he would
always warm up the same way he warmed up
doing the exact word-for-word recording
session of an old Orson Welles
commercial where Orson Welles doesn't
complete the commercial it's about you
know mrs. Covington's fish products or
something and it's basically this
diatribe by Orson Welles of him like
going off copy on his commercial and
getting real ticked off at the engineer
in the booth
get me a jewelry and show me how you end
your long go down on you that was where
the brains voice came from it came from
Maurice just loving this Orson Welles
impression and we said yeah I think
that'll work so was that this is
probably stupid question but was that
the inspiration for yes always which is
a cartoon where the brain goes does a
voice audition and almost quotes
word for word every line that Orson
Welles said in those auditions it is
exactly the inspiration for that for
that particular segment and that's the
only cartoon Animaniacs cartoon in which
I actually did my own voice come on
brain
I write all your best material
Shakespeare wrote my best material you
write drivel unfit for a lightbulb
commercial Peters in it and Andre
romano's in it and basically the brain
is just ripping into us the finest
prairie fed beef and taste this is a lot
of tripe you know that - pretty good
decent piece this is a lot of shit you
know that now your son Nate was the
voice of Skippy squirrel which of course
is a huge part but on top of that maybe
even more iconic he was the voice of
baby plucky from Tiny Toons
and I can tell you right now everybody
in my school was always quoting the
potty years we'd always say when I go
down to hold and I'm wondering Nate how
did you get into this was this something
that you really want to do or did your
father force you to do it or how to work
uh I came to the voice of baby plucky
because actually because of my youngest
brother Cody Cody was two or three at a
time and he was the inspiration for baby
plucky everything we remember baby
plucky for like uh taking everything he
could find and flushing it down the
toilet getting into an elevator and
pushing all the buttons my youngest
brother Cody did that and my dad
probably thought that was good
television was writing that out yeah but
those were cartoons and this is real
life don't tell him he might crack I was
the lead in our first grade production
of your Good Man Charlie Brown so my
seven-year-old brain registered that as
oh I'm going to be a huge actor someday
and I just begged my parents to take me
to like every type of like audition for
movies and theater and um and some
reason they encouraged me I had to get
him out of the city away from all those
bad influences he liked peace and love
exactly so at that point I think it was
a no-brainer for my dad to ask me to do
kind of an impression of my younger
brother Cody as the voice of baby plucky
and so that's pretty much how I got my
first job in show business by making fun
of my baby brother on national
television I knew that I could get my
kids to perform it the way I needed it
to be so it's a kind of almost a control
thing that uh my prob he knows me better
than anyone pretty much and so very
often for a lot of the Skippy episodes
if he didn't write it he was very
involved with the writing so the
dialogue always came out that Skippy
character and his dialogue would fit me
like a glove so it was very easy
it was never strange but it did get
embarrassing
as anyone's father can be but in these
cases there be times the ones I remember
where I was supposed to give a laugh and
it wasn't as big a laugh as they needed
and so my dad would slowly sneak into
the recording booth and start tickling
me and there it was like giggling like
an idiot with my dad tickling me in
front of this room filled with Hollywood
professionals now like Cherry said a lot
of Thompson's for aging it looks like
came from you kids uh was there anything
that you specifically came up with and
made it into the show even though you're
just like a little child at the time
none of my ideas or episodic storylines
or characters or anything like that from
me got into the story got into the show
Animaniacs except for this one line my
dad was working on the main theme for
Animaniacs coming with the lyrics and he
had run out of words that rhymes with
Animaniacs I know that I spent I spent
like a week writing the animaniacs theme
song lyrics and I had like probably had
like seven different versions all with
different words he had doubted cute and
Yakko yaks wacko packs laid the snacks
and didn't have the rest of it it just
so happened that I saw on TV that day
that our current president enjoyed
playing the saxophone in his spare time
so I chimed in with Bill Clinton plays
the sax and that got into the final cut
of the song
it rhymes it's amazing now for all of
you when I think of writers on a show
especially a comedy show
I think of Dick Van Dyke I think of
everybody packed in a room and they're
all shouting ideas and they're saying oh
that's great what's the next line what's
the next line and did the process work
that way or was a very much an
individual process there wasn't like you
know sort of like the Dick Van Dyke
thing where we're all sitting in a room
to go going okay what's the next line we
would all go away and you know sort of
struggle over them over the scripts it
wasn't like you know the sitcom method
where you sit in a room you break a
story and you know everybody kind of
throws out their two cents you would
come up with ideas for characters for um
different stories for different
characters and you done pitched the idea
of Tom and he'd say yeah that sounds
good go write it that kind of thing I do
remember that Paul Rugg wrote a lot of
the Warner Brothers cartoons because he
was especially good at that Paul you
know god bless him he's one of the
funniest people on earth and one of the
most intelligent writers on earth but
boy when he's into a script and and he's
struggling with it when it's not going
perfectly heat it's like you can just
see the pain I remember I was having
problems when with a an episode called
hearts of Twilight was a parody of a
hearts of darkness and sometimes you get
yourselves into really into a big
problem because you're like boy it
wouldn't be funny if the Warner's had to
go up studio in a golf cart and sort of
stop a director who was making spending
millions of dollars and that director
would be you know mr. director sort of
Jerry Lewis and stuff and and I was like
oh that's a great idea let's you know
and I think I wrote the first two pages
of that for like a week and a half and
finally I was like I didn't know what to
do so I went into Tom's office and I
said Tom I
I just don't get it I think I should
work on something else and and I
remember the only time Tom never got mad
at me he said no this is too expensive
you need to finish it so um so I went
back in my room and cried a little bit
and then I sort of figured it out so
you're a satirizing a documentary about
a person slowly going crazy
while making a movie about a person
slowly going crazy and you yourself were
slowly going crazy I've made me cry but
you know it was fun I'm over now
it happened because Paul rug was writing
in that room for like three weeks and
his like brain was bleeding and it
finally came out well how'd you what the
going you were there but hang out from
the look of things it seemed like
there's a lot of freedom and I I know
it's a cliche to be like they don't
weaken the communities but it always
does sort of seem like that and I guess
what I'm wondering is was Animaniacs
just one of those rare experiences where
everything just seemed to go right and
everything clicked or are these
experiences really like the dime a dozen
well that was really my first real
writing job um and so I I now have
learned that uh it's it doesn't go that
well you know it's like we got our
dessert first in animation and then you
know this time why not we learned what
beans tasted like some of the head guys
at Warner Brothers the the big
mucky-muck said well you can't do shorts
whatever you do don't do shorts and we
said well why not
and so because there's no precedent no
no one knows how to do them yeah you
have no model to follow which is
hilarious because of course there's
third there were 35 40 years of these
gems these seven-minute gem snow shows
it's you know free act structure you
know you know what you're going to do
stories have a beginning middle and
they're half hours they're to 11 minutes
you know it's much more simpler and
easier on the editing budget quite a few
of the writers that eventually came on
to work on Animaniacs were people that I
knew through sketch comedy and they
weren't um animation writers per se when
they started out in fact not at all John
McCann and Paul Riga and Peter Hastings
and Deanna Oliver these these are people
that I all knew from sketch comedy the
first thing that they wanted to be was
funny none of us knew exactly the wrong
way to do it so or the right way to do
it so we
did the best we could in the funniest
way we could mostly we had Tom Ruger as
a great producer and he would you know
he would bring us all in people would
say well I think I want to write one
where they they goof on Albert Einstein
and normal it was like great you you
have a go go do that that that that'll
be great and today in the lot of shows
I've been I've been doing um you can say
yeah I want to have them goof on Albert
Einstein and then select like a good go
away and write exactly what that would
be but don't write it so you do sort of
a three-page outline about what'll
happen the nice thing about annum
Animaniacs was we didn't really there
was really none of that you'd get
assigned a script and that'd be your
script
it was loose I mean ultimately it was
your job to get the script done and get
it in but you know you had plenty out
there to get you through the rough spot
there was a lot of freedom um
we didn't really have a lot of people
hovering over us telling us what to do
or telling us that that was
inappropriate to do or that kids
wouldn't get this or that or the other I
personally never had as much freedom
before or after then I had during the
Animaniacs sometimes in a network there
are like you know 50 people reading your
script and you'll get competing notes
from different people and we didn't
really have that it went to Tom ruger go
off to Steven Spielberg and and that was
it we were very very lucky in that
regard I mean it certainly changed now
this was at the dawn of the imitatable
behavior thing so you know they were
afraid that any any behavior with a
common household object that the
children could imitate would you know in
turn lead them to do that and then you
know trigger a lawsuit it's certain
educational elements that have to be
involved when you're dealing with
certain hours of the day for television
and all of that stuff that I still don't
understand there is a scene of Dracula
Dracula where something about turning
into a bat Wakko pulls out an actual
baton and hits the vampire well they
they didn't care for that you know they
said you can't use uh can't use a real
bat Tom Ruger and a masterful stroke got
around it by putting
on the wooden path and somehow that that
made it okay so a bat with bat wings was
okay but a bat without bat wings was
corrupting the youth of America all I
guys say is that I'm glad most houses
don't have an VLEs and malice lying
around right dynamite except for certain
areas of the southwest no we're good
safe there if we got any sort of inkling
that somebody wanted us to be more
educational or or have more of a theme
then we would mark that like with the
wheel of morality that sort of thing
wheel of morality turn turn turn
tell us the lesson that we should learn
moral number two and the moral of
today's story is